la guerre en ukraine un conflit qui a
déjà des répercussions conséquentes sur
les économies et la hausse des prix de
l'énergie notable dans de nombreux pays
comme l'espagne on va vous en parler ou
les prix à la consommation ont augmenté
bondit même de 9 8% en mars sur un an
c'est leur plus forte hausse depuis mai
1985 conséquences vraiment de pedro de
sanchez confronté à une grogne sociale
qui monte a été contraint hier de sortir
le carnet de chèques je vous propose des
contes et tout de suite les premiers
ministres espagnol
nous constatons les effets de cette
guerre sur l'augmentation du coût de la
vie mais ce que le gouvernement promet
c'est de tout faire pour diminuer ses
effets sur la population avec un plan de
6 milliards d'euros d'investissements
jusqu'au 30 juin à travers des aides
directes des baisses d'impôts en plus
des 10 milliards d'euros qui vont être
transférés sous la forme de crédits pour
amortir les conséquences de la crise sur
les familles les entreprises et les
entités les plus vulnérables
a retrouvé tout tu t'en en direct de
madrid notre correspondant de céline
schmitt bonjour à céline le gouvernement
de perrault sanchez qu'elles ont décidé
de mettre les moyens pour tenter
d'apaiser la colère sociale avec des
mesures très concrètes
oui effectivement donc l'inflation tirée
par la hausse des prix de l'énergie
c'est une épine dans le pied depuis
plusieurs mois pour pedro sanchez une
situation qui s'est donc vous l'avez
compris largement aggravée avec
l'invasion de l'ukraine qui a fait
flamber les prix de l'énergie on l'a vu
le gouvernement de près de sanchez a
donc adopté hier un vaste plan national
de réponse aux conséquences de la guerre
en ukraine avec donc des baisses
d'impôts et des aides directes qui
s'élève à 6 milliards d'euros un volet
important de ce plan daide qui est déjà
bien connue maintenant c'est donc cette
subvention de 20 centimes d'euros par
litre de carburant qui s'adresse donc à
tous les espagnols ces mesures elles ont
donc un objectif vous l'avez dit c'est
mettre fin à la grogne sociale qui s'est
installé depuis plusieurs même
maintenant ici en espagne on a vu la
manifestation des agriculteurs des
pêcheurs des manifestations contre le
prix du gaz contre le prix de
l'électricité est un mouvement qui dure
toujours c'est le mouvement des
transporteurs routiers ils pauthe ils
protestent tous pardon contre une chose
c'est cette vie chère qui donc comme on
l'a vu a atteint des records avec ce 10
% d'inflation qui est donc un chiffre
historique du jamais vu ici en espagne
depuis 37 ans en tout cas pedro sanchez
et se veut rassurant il est convaincu
que sa stratégie aura des effets très
rapide sur le niveau de vie des
espagnols
merci beaucoup c'est un jeu mettant en
direct donc de madrid après cette
réponse du goût